one of the most high profile republican  adam laxalt looking to unseat democrat  catherine cortez masto these results  showing it is close to the margin of  error steve sibelius saying these  candidates will have to make themselves  stand out  they're going to have to have a plan to  address this this kind of inflation and  and those type of things uh the  association with biden and to the extent  that people believe joe biden is  responsible for those problems and are  people in his party too close to him  you're going to see a lot of ads saying  so and so votes with biden 90 percent of  the time all that kind of stuff to  associate them with a very unpopular  figure that joe biden is